again that wasn't it okay it's early
signing day for the rebels they picked
up
19 players it's expected to be the top
class in the mountain west conference
we'll see if that can translate into
some victories
would be nice some great news for high
school players in the valley and nobody
does signing day better than our john
treach
the pandemic can steal their senior
season but not their heart
not their hope not their history what a
town
what a day i could have gave up plenty
of times with my lifestyle but
i chose to work hard and grind for
something i want
aaron joins teammate evan leaving legacy
high school
and leaving a freaking legacy i think
it's a huge step and it's very exciting
for me to be able to go to play at the
next level
and to be able to continue to do what i
love
junior carmona is the big man on campus
at las vegas high
and he's ready to be big time at san
jose state during 2020 it's
there's not much that's exciting so
today is definitely going to be a great
day and i'm going to celebrate it a lot
jarrett robinson ran by defenders at
centennial and right
into the rockies you can't get this day
back in and that's what i want to
cherish this with my family
and my friends and everybody they really
mean everything to me dion washington is
a proud las vegas but his college
compass
is taking him north the coaches wanted
me like from the gym they didn't take
any recruiting process they saw my tape
and offered me on the spot
desert pines has become a football
factory they don't get much more
promising than this scholarship
season five the first one in my family
go to college so this is uh this is
pretty big for me a lot of joy to be
able to come to celebrate
me signing and watching my boys sign
it's a lot of joy
it's like a dream come true you know
we've been we've been talking about this
day since we were freshmen
but yeah i'm just proud to be a part of
this program
and then there is iconic liberty forever
connected in the way they chase
challenged and became champions growing
up
you know i started on my church and i
found my talent in football
so that's why i was more emotional
because now you know i have a glimpse of
greatness right now i'm gonna tell my
kids about this and i'm gonna tell my
grandkids about this so
honestly this team and just all my
coaches and all my brothers here at
liberty is just it's amazing it's just
awesome
seeing through all the ups and downs of
this year you know kind of like a roller
coaster raining on a high note
and where you know we're going to make
something special of all of us las vegas
is best signed scholarships
but they're writing history john treach
8 sports now
congratulations to all the signees today
brian back to you